so there's a fascinating TED talk by the
brilliant Esther Perel author of mating
in captivity where she explores the
secret to desire in long-term
relationships because this of course is
the Holy Grail
you know falling in love is easy the
honeymoon period anybody would take that
ride but what happens upon the moment
that routine becomes you know part of
your reality the person you're with
every single day how do you retain that
passion that fire this is again the
mystery of long-term desire and Esther
Perel she went around the world asking
couples when are you most drawn to your
partner and in what she found across the
board everyone said the same thing
they found their partner the most
attractive when they were able to see
their partner as a self-sustaining
entity it's this idea that they were
able to perceive their partner the way
that other people perceive them as a
complete individual as a complete
self-sustaining person not the other
half of you but as a solid whole and
until this idea that attraction requires
a kind of distance that even desire
requires a crossing over she says and I
thought that was absolutely brilliant
because how can we incorporate that into
our own relationships how can we create
space between us and the ones we love so
that we can reclaim that crossing over
so that we can see them as that
self-sustaining entity and fully
appreciate them as the fully rounded
complete thing that they are I think
she's onto something that Esther Perel
for that reason if a she's brilliant and
I think everybody should watch that TED
talk because you know if we can hack if
we could hack the secret to desire in
the long term that could solve a lot of
our problems